こんにちははじめシャツ大です皆さん走りますか走るときにもっともず様となってくる
と言っても過言ではないものがあるんですけども
えっすごい大事だと思うんですよ靴で結構走るスピードとかかおるんじゃないかなと
思ってる人間なんですけど皆さん
ムーンっスーパーシーってご存知でしょうか
昔 com
ウッダーさんのシューズの党が出したことあるんですけれども
今回なんとムーンスターだからスーパーたーーーーシリーズの最新モデル
アルティメーターライトというものが発売されるそうです
はいこちらでございますめっちゃ軽いです
本来は子ども用の曲なので小さいサイズしかないんですけども
私のために特注を用意させて頂いてもらい私のために特注のサイズを作って頂きました
本当にありがとうございます山ぽんち
めっちゃくちゃ軽くて歩いてみたいと軽いだけじゃなくてバネの力がこのソールの部分
に搭載されていましたこれかな
難波ネっぽいのがここには
んですけども軽いだけじゃなくてそのバネの力を利用して速く走れるっていう
シューズになっておりますそこで私
木棒を覚えてしまいました形で本当にシューズで
馳せる速度って変わるのかひょっとしたら裸足で走ったほうが早いかもんそんなこと
ないと思うんですけどあえて見えたライトじゃない
スポーツシューズで走ってもタイも変わらないんじゃないかなあみたいなちょっと良く
ない考えがよぎっておりましてそれを5回ちゃんと検証して本当に荒れてメーター
ライトをはくと
早く走れるのかどうかいろんなパターンに走ってみて検証していきたいとおもいます
日は以下僕も入っていうわけでまずは最初普通の靴で走ってみます
走る距離はちなみに50メートルで測るんですけども
あのそもそも僕多分あってるんですよまずでちょっとやばい50m 走れる体力がある
かどうかという戦いもあるんですけど
まあ普通の靴で走るんでこれが僕の基本的なタイムだと思って結構です
緊張するし倒れたらどうするよまあやるからには
記事書いてるんだよ
イヤーッ
聞いていてー
8位
[音楽]
me
nan
かもしれんえっ
どうですかタイムの方はう
ナビを15約5杯
これが基準タイムまそうですねという意味でね7秒15が僕の基準タイムです
早くないですかなんか適度に運動するから意外と明日の回転力が高いのかもしれない
ですよ
こっからいろんな普通の靴以外でどれくらいタイムが変動するか見ていくんで
まあここからがお楽しみのところです次行きましょう
はいというわけで次は運動会のお決まりパターン
話でございます
なんかよく入れないですが運動会のあの最後の団体氷で
であのアンカーの男はたいてい裸足で走る
あれは本当に見合うのかどうかっていうのもこれでバトルと思うんでちょっと肌セブ
タイム早いかどうか結構気になるところだと思うんで見ていきましょうん
やるからには
世界獲りたいです
wiki について
[音楽]
ああああああ
どうですかタイムの方は七尾を
06をちょっと早くなるのか
靴が重い分ちょっと軽くなった可能性がありますね
1そうそう限界かもしれですと池田団対抗リレーの話で走るアンカーの男
っぱなしで走って間違いないと思います
次行きましょうおーいおとうぞうしましたブースター
スーパースターシリーズ rg メーターライト
こちらです
声てが色合いがもう洒落
いやすっごいやっぱば音の感じがするんで
果たしてこの超軽量のアルティメットアーライト
そして晩年の力でどこまでタイムが縮まるのかこれでを9秒台が出せば本当に速くなる
というのが証明できると思うんで頑張りますまでの力を信じます
やるからには
関わー
8位
ああああああああああああああ
キリないと結果ですなー日を
30ターンはぁ
[音楽]
ブーブーあったら絶対ログですけどそろそろすょあれ秘めたライトマジで多分多くの
体感的には早く橋
れましたですがまだ実験は終わっていません次行きましょう
ちょっとも体力が
機械ですのぞみ社長ですね1回目良かったんですけど2回目な形でちょっと足の裏に
痛みを感じ
3回目は残された有力でなんとかバネのチカラを借りて最速タイムを出せたんですけど
誰の力ってやっぱ凄いと思ったわけですよ
そこでもつられてメーターライトの晩年を作らもすごかったんですけど根本的に地面に
までの力を搭載すれば最速タイムが出ると思ったのでこちらをご覧ください
ん
[音楽]
学校の体育の授業の二よく使われるときもこのロイター板
ふみっキリ番を
50m サーフの例の中にたくさん用意しました絵本から気づいたんですよ
バッジの力はいい
具体だということアルティメーターライト卵だけ早く慣れるということは
面すべてに踏み切り板場でのつからを装備させるともっと速くなるんじゃないか
僕はおそらくこの踏切ただけの例を使って世界最速タイも敵だと思う
刮目せよ
いざ
いただきます
[音楽]
までの作られ目指し世界
道に付いて用意
ああああああ
ああああああああ
を合わせるふともを釣る人ももうすぐ
気になるタイムは
今の債務やん
7 b 87まぁそうなるわなはいというわけでいろんな
シューズは釣り形で実験してみたところ一番ある方は
スーパースターシリーズアルティメーターライトでございました
ただ1個言わせてください
あのほんとで裸足で走った後あたりからマジで体力なくて
絶対最初に走ってたら6秒台でたんですよ
でももうこの体力限界の中でも含めたライトで最速でも出せたんで速く走れることに
間違いないと思いますやっぱり軽いのとバネの力が本当にた分しっかり効果が出てたん
だなと思いました
であの踏切バウンドで走るのは
やめておきましょう
だけでバネの力を存分に発揮できるのはスーパースターシリーズだけだと思います
あとねあの果たしで走れるのは運動会の
団対抗リレーのアンカーとかさカッコいいと思うんですけどもまぁ足の裏が痛くなるの
でよく
避けたほうがいいと思いますというわけで疲れきった僕でも最速タイムを出した
アルティメーターないと最新ラインナップ
おまいらや渋滞もございますメッツかっこいいです
詳しくは動画の概要欄にあるんで是非チェックしてみてください皆さんもバネのチカラ
大一貫してみてはいかがでしょうかじゃーん
me
あっはっ